un vote à main levée en petit comité à
l'unanimité les membres de la chambre
civile de la région de luhansk plaide
pour l'instauration d'un référendum sur
le rattachement de la région à la russie
les habitants du dombass ont déjà fait
leur choix en 2014 lors d'un référendum
d'autodétermination
nous avons attendu et espéré en second
référendum toutes ces années qui nous
permettrait d'intégrer la russie
quelques instants plus tard les régions
de donetsk de kherson de zappos ridja
dans le sud leur ont emboîté le pas le
scrutin a été fixé du 23 au 27 septembre
prochain
l'issue de ces quatre référendum ne fait
guère de doute ils interviennent alors
que les troupes russes perdent du
terrain et manque d'hommes et d'armes
moscou cherche ainsi à sécuriser ses
conquêtes territoriales
tout d'abord c'est une tentative
d'établir les frontières de ces
territoires là où se trouve la ligne de
front
deuxièmement cela donnera à la russie la
possibilité de présenter les tentatives
ukrainienne de reprendre ces régions
comme une attaque directe de l'ukraine
contre la russie alors la guerre sera
déclarée et il pourrait mener une
mobilisation forcer
la tenue de tels scrutins n'aurait
aucune légitimité démocratique
les autorités pro russes veulent calquer
ses référendum sur celui de 2014 qui a
permis à la russie d'annexer la
péninsule ukrainienne de crimée un vote
qui n'a pas été reconnue par la
communauté internationale